foreign
you say that dark matter doesn't exist
run out falsification is the key words
you test the one Theory Dark Matter
exists tested is falsified with more
than five Sigma it doesn't exist you
drop it you don't even touch it anymore
ever in Armada search troop group we do
not touch dark matter anymore right
Jessica disagree on that come in and try
to explain why we haven't all stopped
working on dark matter I think within
the Dark Matter model the reason we
haven't just all said well okay this is
just inconsistent we're going to stop
working on it
is that it's really quite a complicated
question how fast Galaxy should be
moving and the Dark Matter model has
been so successful at explaining other
observations that I really think we
should just be working on both
um you know I think having some people
working on dark matter and some people
working on modified gravity is probably
a reasonable Division I might interject
here because I hear the statement many
times that the Dark Matter models of
course the cosmological Dark Matter
models have been successful in
accounting of a large variety of
observations it is wrong
I don't know any single observation
which has actually been successfully
reproduced by by the Dark Matter models
one case
if you look at the account the number of
galaxies within our surroundings you go
out to hundreds of millions of light
years you can count the number of
galaxies per unit space you have right
and we see that the density of matter
increases out to
um about
um
1500 million light years so that's
already a large distance
um and um which means we live in a
gigantic under density this is called
the KBC void which was discovered by
Keenan bag and Kobe in 2012 and it's
been verified by subsequent studies also
looking at the number of Galaxy clusters
we believe in a region of cosmological
space which has a lower mass density a
smaller number of Galaxy clusters
smaller number of galaxies than further
out now that huge and void is completely
inconsistent with the Lambda CDM model
there have been you know some things
there are predictions in the more normal
sense
um so for example if Dark Matter exists
and Einstein's theory of general
relativity is broadly speaking correct
even at large scales than we would
expect to observe
um the bending of light around dark
matter this is called gravitational
lensing and then you know indeed we have
observed that
so there are some things where you can
kind of make predictions and see them
but with a lot of science these days and
particularly a lot of fundamental
physics there's so much input that needs
to go into every calculation you have to
make so many assumptions and everyone
has to do that we have to do it you have
to do it if you're calculating and
modify gravity you have to do that to
calculate anything that it can be quite
hard to disentangle exactly what's the
prediction and what's just consistency
within the theory there's a very
beautiful test which falsifies the Dark
Matter existence with more than 12 Sigma
confidence and that's a Galaxy's built
up bars in the center so the whole this
galaxy is becomes that a little bit
unstable and it forms a bar like
structure if you look at pictures of
galaxies you can see the round this
galaxy the spiral patterns and there's a
bar in many of them yeah now this bar is
a solid Rotator it can it has to be a
solid rotating structure otherwise it
wouldn't be a bar it's not a spiral
pattern this structure is a huge amount
of mass which actually moves around like
a spoon in coffee and it hits up the
Dark Matter hell around it in that
theory and therefore it slows down
because it gives its up its moving
energy to the dark matter which absorbs
it and the Dark Matter Halos puffs up a
little bit that slow down is radically
not seen in the data it's 12 Sigma which
is much much more than five Sigma
totally not there in the data this is
why I'm so completely confident there is
no dark matter I mean as a scientist I
would be ruining my reputation if I
would be climbing around in the um in
the landscape there is no dark matter
where my colleague next door a famous
Professor tells me there is dark matter
but I have to follow the scientific
evidence which tells me there is
absolutely no dark matter
the podcast talks debates courses and
articles visit the Institutes of Art and
ideas click the link on screen now to
IAI dot TV